we usually get up about 7:00 and I
usually get up a little later I make
coffee for both of us I like honey and
cream in my cafe and then I almost
always drive to work our morning routine
is quite Monday oh yeah one thing we're
doing today is a fire-breathing dragon
finishing off that yeah and I've got
some stuff to blood and some skulls and
pumpkins I'm Marcia this is my husband
Edie
and we run distortions unlimited we make
monsters zombies aliens dragons and
beasts of all kinds oh my most of what
we make is scary I will say that we make
monsters for everyone from home Haunter
all the way up to amusement parks and
big events all around the world we've
been working together for 35 years it's
been glorious yeah wonderful
[Music]
we started out painting together I fell
in love very quickly we've been married
almost 25 years we've found a way to
work together I'm probably more on the
business side and it is probably more in
the production I can't tell you how many
people have told me I could never work
with my spouse and that's too bad
because you miss half or more of that
whole person's life if you don't
[Music]
I think people expect us to be a little
bit weirder than the yarn we're actually
a little bit boring when we get in the
car and go home it's over we love
monsters we just we've had enough of it
after a long day there's a separation
there there has to be you'd go crazy if
somebody walked into our house they
wouldn't have a clue what we do in fact
we keep it all kind of secret yeah
people are surprised about that with us
we like it that way
it's really special to do something you
love with somebody you love we make
monsters but whatever our personalities
kind of mesh with each other so it works
out you know you really can establish a
good relationship as you're dripping
zombie blood that's the kind of woman I
need in my life
[Music]
okay i'm louis and i'm charlie and we
have been told and we believe that we
have the largest private collection of
insects in the world yeah the story of
how we met was interesting enough i was
a teaching assistant at the university
of arizona and Louis was a student in
the class that I was teaching we've been
married for almost 55 years he's got a
million stories about insects all of
which I've heard and all of which I can
fill in sentences and we've traveled
extensively have been to all the
continents and 70 countries collecting
it fills us with pleasure to get into
the field and collect to spend the time
in the field together oh you need to
look at the antenna on one of these it
looks like a clown shoe well I study
weevils and the weevils are the largest
family of living organisms these are
plant hoppers and I think their noses
are - I collect plant hoppers which are
insects that feed on the juices of
plants the phloem or the xylem with
piercing sucking mouthparts
with piercing sucking mouthparts oh yeah
when when we get some insects in they're
just dead of course we have to mount
them so we have to pin them or point
point them and then we label um
the glue was not stiff enough and he's
fallen off his point then after I do
that then I sort him to genus each of
these units Trace holds 55 specimens on
average and we have at least a million
weevils and a quarter of a million
flying hours okay here you come darling
we are donating the collection to
Arizona State University and there will
be research done on it which is what we
wanted to have happen when we were
entomologists at the university we've
worked 14 hours a day seven days a week
now we're down to eight to ten hours a
day seven days a week it's a lot of work
but we both loved what we were doing and
it was sharing that it was part of our
life yeah which one do you think is the
prettiest these two I don't like that
one Louis has often taken note the fact
that a very large number of
entomologists are divorced what I
recommend is if you're going to be a tax
on Alyssa systematists collect insects
you get a spouse is another entomologist
you
kim chaemin or Inara roecastle take
apart any ordinary sashimi ko Chow
antennas are anita bidden day Chanin kim
jung-han namida heroin is essentially
Santana hari omma she grew Hasina Krong
kimchi Ashanti's Anna Choi auntie auntie
heh ha meaty riparian vegetation
kikuchiyo cheddar ajamila dominica
kimchi girl Bunga Chenega and attempt
una juerga - Chrissa
Oh Jung yon from cha da mata ashita in
English Channel
Koo Kim Chi Hachiya Audrina Oh che puta
kadhi kadhi determination Tina bidding
Jojo
Masha Tarawa P under and kimchi Nanyang
kim jongseo amezo Asakura Mensa or
kimchi random puny or Munna Pietra that
eventually reach Hadassah youngnam
Naruto gmod Yong ha ha
banner Sangha Iran and Young America
chocolate catchy hunky so closed off
canard Agha Jones of sorrow Youkilis an
extrinsic abandon Kim chicka-chicka
Mandarin kimchi jjigae van wanted and
eternal from eating to me tiramisu cake
Amnon vendor portal diamonds are ruined
our economy Leo to pop open the Retiro
to Imperial era Kaiser Terauchi whom a
TOEIC in Chiba our get division
crush saga kombucha condo and a Romans
or chicken cage a home on a pro review
ducati Kasich had a leak in China or
Iran human rights marijuana centimeter
high cherish Kimmy are we Oh hogwash and
younger than Iran rotated Erica sagon
first came the grasses they came in
thick then smaller shrubs
with them the insects returned then the
trees and with the trees the monkeys and
elephants here at precise sanctuary
we have over 300 acres a forest that we
have replanted and brought back to life
[Music]
my full name is Pamela Gayle multi-track
and I am co-founder with my husband of
size sanctuary trust it had always been
our dream to have a private forest
sanctuary for wildlife where they would
be protected when we first came here
most of the lands that were sold to us
were abandoned lands abandoned rice
field coffin and Hardiman fields as well
a lot of deforestation had taken place
and that took a lot a lot of care and
energy and time and years to bring it
back to really done well this year
people thought you were quite crazy but
that's okay a lot of people have thought
people that have done some amazing
things are crazy here in the sanctuary
it is a biodiversity hotspot I remember
walking through the forest you wouldn't
hear anything but the sound of your own
feet now the place is alive with sound
[Music]
one of our main sound makers are the
cicadas they have a tremendous decibel
range where they start again we keep
striving to do more and more but the
initial goal has been more than achieved
my hope for the next 10 years for this
forest is that it will continue to be
protected and expanded we both feel a
tremendous amount of joy when we walk
through the sanctuary I've never felt
this kind of joy than anything else that
I've done in my life
[Music]
[Music]
we are a circus a big family tradition I
would the way we present our show is the
same way that my family presented the
show over 175 years ago there's nothing
fancy about what we do here it's magic
real magic we grew up in a circus as a
child you just step into being a clown
we're a classic family circus which
means our families here working together
performing together first of all is my
mother the matriarch of our family then
I have my sister Carla who with her
husband Rudy they perform with her dog
act and then way my sister Tosca she has
two horses on the show but she also
directs the show her husband J is an
amazing white clown the white clown is
the stray clock he's the best white con
that I've ever seen
fact that my son and I do right now in a
show is actually a balloon routine it's
nothing new I mean it's thousands of
years old cause haven't done it forever
it happens to be really cute when he
does it because he's adorable
it's an it's an unexplainable thing to
see my child do what he loves to do I
mean this egg it's a seven-year-old
beautiful little boy that his heart
opens up and he gives it to everybody
it's different here I think than most
places when we come into this ring we
become family
I believe circus and family are
basically the same word
[Music]